welcome back to the show remember that
we are mostly funded by individual
memberships one of which you can get at
joinpackman.com that also gets you the
daily
bonus show more show every day
for those who choose it sign up at
joinpackman.com
so we learned this weekend that donald
trump will be fighting back
against i guess twitter and facebook and
cancel culture i don't know by making a
triumphant return to social media
in two to three months on his own
platform maybe it will be called trump
book
or maybe it will be called twit trump
or trumpogram who knows here is
perpetual
never-ending infinity trump brown-noser
jason miller
explaining this on fox news just a
couple of days ago
donald trump obviously has been booted
off twitter and facebook and instagram
which were a great megaphone for him
does he plan
to try to get back on social media
perhaps with some new outfit
you know harry this is really
interesting the fact that the
president's been off of social media for
a while because
his press releases his statements have
actually been getting almost more play
than he ever did on twitter before
now that's completely untrue jason
miller as usual
is lying trump having the bully pulpit
on twitter
dwarfed those bizarre sometimes almost
sad and pathetic press releases he's
been putting out but that's not the key
part here
the key part is jason miller telling us
trump is launching
a social media network i'm not sure if
that's because the length of them were a
bit longer i even had
one reporter say that she thought it was
much more elegant
the way that the president was able to
communicate his thoughts and very much
looked more presidential in that longer
form
but i do think that we're going to see
president trump returning
to social media and probably about two
or three months here with his own
platform
and this is something i think will be
the the hottest ticket in social media
it's going to completely redefine the
game
and everybody is going to be waiting and
watching to see what exactly president
trump does but it will be his own
platform
so just to follow up will this be a
platform that
the president the former president will
create himself we working with another
company and obviously he'll be starting
from scratch he won't start out with 88
million twitter followers
well i can't go much further than what i
was able to just share but i can say
that it will be big once he starts
there's been a lot of high-powered
meetings he's been having at mar-a-lago
with some teams of folks who've been
coming in and i gotta tell you there's
been it's not just
one company that's approached the
president there's been numerous
companies
but i think the president does know what
direction that he wants to head here
and this new platform is going to be big
and everyone wants them he's gonna bring
millions and millions tens of millions
of people to this new platform look at
the hyperbole
it will be the hottest ticket in social
media
even hotter maybe i guess than parlor
and gab and i love the reference to uh
high-powered meetings with teams of
folks
teams of folks have been flocking to
mar-a-lago
for high-powered meetings so anyway it's
very clear
that donald trump is in various ways
testing
whether he should or could successfully
run
in 2024 part of that is what donald
trump announced that that cpac speech at
the end of february that
you can donate to his pack save america
and he will play king maker don't donate
to the republican party if you donate to
the republican party
they might put money towards so-called
rhinos republicans in name only
trump doesn't like people like mitt
romney trump
if you donate to him will decide which
republicans are worthy of support
he will primary the bad republicans that
he has identified
he will support the pro-trump
republicans and as we said before
if he can do that if he can wield that
degree of power
it helps him to look stronger for 2024.
here of course
recognizing that twitter was a big part
of his winning in 2016 in the first
place
being absent on twitter now because he's
banned
he's going to try to create an
alternative all with the same purpose
to regain that power and to rebuild his
bully pulpit now will it actually happen
because remember that back in
august of 2020 or july even we were just
two weeks away from getting trump's new
health care plan which he was going to
roll out it was going to be perfect it
was going to be signed into law it was
going to replace obamacare
never came out and donald trump's gone
and back in 2015 donald trump said he
would release
his tax returns and he never did so lots
of things that trump claims he will do
or others claim trump will do never end
up happening i have no idea
it may happen it may not what we can be
absolutely certain of
is that if donald trump does launch a
social media platform
it will very quickly become a central
node
of disinformation propaganda it's also
funny to hear jason miller say
trump is going to redefine social media
it's always so endlessly hyperbolic
it's the same thing they said about
trump's presidency now
in a sense trump redefined the
presidency
to the point of bad in showing how
corrupt a president could be
but redefining it in terms of finally
draining the swamp and
changing everything you know it okay he
was the most corrupt
administrator in the modern political
era
but that's not exactly a change i'd be
bragging about so maybe we'll see more
of the same with the social media thing
maybe it'll just never happen as so many
of the things that are promised
never do but the latest is trump will
return
with his own social media platform let
me know what you think it should be
called
i'm terrible at this stuff trumpogram
and trump book
is the only thing i could come up with
um because i'm just completely
uncreative
but i know some of you will have some
better ideas
many so-called healthy snacks
don't taste that great they don't fill
you up they don't satisfy a craving
which is why you should check out our
sponsor
monk pack and their keto nut and seed
bars
delicious sweet snacks with only a gram
of sugar or less
two to three grams of net carbs and just
150 calories
perfect for the keto or low carb diet
or anybody who just generally tries to
eat a low sugar diet
like me i love the monk pack keto nut
and seed bars
just a great balance of sweet and salty
soft and chewy but with a nice
crunch from the nuts and seeds you can
get
great flavors like caramel not caramel
come on guys
caramel sea salt sea salt dark chocolate
peanut butter dark chocolate that's my
personal favorite they'll give you
all of your money back if you don't love
it go to monkpack.com the link is down
below and you'll get 20 percent off any
of their products
when you use the coupon code pacman